We wrote an article using the same exact
keyword and settings. And here are the
results. One article scored 51 out of
100 in terms of SEO optimization. And
the second article scored 71 out of 100
in terms of SEO optimization. In today's
video, let's go through the winner
between Word Rocket and Content Pen. I
signed up for a plan on Content Pen
because I wanted to see how it compared
over to Word Rocket. And in today's
video, I'll be doing a completely
unbiased review. Now, there were some
things that I definitely liked when
signing up for Content Pen. I like the
onboarding. It allowed you to enter in
your domain and then we already had
preset knowledge and preset um sort of
tonality based upon the website uh that
it scraped. So, it was able to fetch the
information for my brand very easily.
And they also gave me some keywords that
I can go ahead and start writing about
and recommended keywords that we can
start writing about. So, I like that.
like right off the bat, it takes off
some of the heavy lifting and the
thinking for you. Now, I went ahead and
generated a couple of articles here. As
you can see, some articles generated
with no problems, while I did have some
generation issues with two articles last
night. Let's go ahead and take a look at
the article that we generated. As we can
see, the article actually doesn't look
bad at all. We get a nice introduction
here. We get a couple of internal links
as well. We get a pull quote key
takeaways with an image here that was AI
generated and I think the image actually
is not bad. Um, not a horrible image,
not a superb image, but I would say a
good decent quality image. Even this
image I would say here is pretty decent.
If I scroll in, I don't see too many
distortions on the faces. I have to
really really look. Um, now is that an
accurate image of Niagara Falls?
Probably not, but it did a pretty good
job. So again, we get some internal
links. You also get some external links
as well. The article looks fairly well
formatted. Again, here's another AI
image in which we're able to get back.
Not bad by any means. We get another
image here which looks pretty good as
well. And another image and overall the
article looks well and we also get an
FAQ towards the end of the article. We
can actually toggle. We can see the
outline. We can see the SER analysis.
So, it actually went out and searched
the SER. Uh we can see the SER
knowledge. So, we went ahead and and did
more information. are gathered more
information about the topic and then we
also have our brand knowledge which is
based upon our specific brand and
website. So overall I wouldn't say that
this was a bad article by any means. Now
after doing a test on new and writer on
the left hand side you have the article
here from content pen and content plan
got 51 out of 100 and again this is
strictly from neuron writer so 51 out of
100 in terms of content optimization and
around 2,400 words. So we see it fell
short in actually doing a basic
optimization of your H1's, your H2s and
including your heading terms and your uh
in paragraph terms as well. I then went
ahead and wrote the same article on Word
Rocket. So as you can see it's on the
same exact topic and we scored a 71 out
of 100. Now I did not change any
settings in this. Um it was exactly as
we did it in New Writers. Let's go back
over to Word Rocket for one second. I
did not change any setting here. If we
head over to articles, we can see that
guided Niagara Falls tour from Toronto
2026 guide. This is the exact article
that we were able to get back from Word
Rocket. But again, Word Rocket did score
higher at 71 out of 100. And if you take
a look anecdotally at the article, I
would say that Word Rocket is a bit
better. Some things that stands out is
that now we have the ability to actually
add your brand logo into the images. So,
as you can see within these images,
we've went ahead and added in specific
brand logo for that brand. So, it just
makes the content way way more on with
all of my with all of my as with most of
my comparisons, I would recommend that
you go out and try both of these tools
out for yourselves. When it comes to the
real meat of what a tool is, when it
comes when it comes to the real power
usage of a tool like this, which is your
content writing, I would say that word
rocket definitely does better in its
output quality in its output output
unique.
When it comes to the main when it comes
to the main feature of writing SEO
optimized unique engaging content, I
would say that Word Rocket does better.
Our content is more unique, especially
with the ability to add your logos in
images. Our images are just better and
the overall quality and SEO optimization
as you saw is higher when we compare it
to Content Pen. But I definitely
recommend that you go out, you try it
for yourself, and you be the judge. If
you want to get Word Rocket, I'll leave
a link below for a coupon where you can
get some money off of each plan. If
you'd like to try Word Rocket for
yourselves, there'll be a link in the
description below today's video. Hope
that you guys enjoyed this one. I'll see
you in the next one. Take care.
Images. We got a nice chart there. I
like that. Another image. Um, another
image of a wine tour. And we see a
frozen Niagara Falls. And again, some
couple other images here. Question ends
in the FAQ. doesn't really end in a
traditional conclusion, but that's okay.
So, now I'm going to do the same thing
and we're going to test this article.
Okay, so we're going to copy over the
article here. We've already loaded up
Nur Writer
and we see that ContentPen gets gets a
49 and we see that Content Pen gets a 49
out of 100. And here's the article that
we got back from Word Rocket best Nagra
Tours of 2026. Again, we're going to
copy over the same article here. We're
going to pop it into New Writer, make no
changes, and Word Rocket got a 68 out of
100. So, we can see on both tests, Word
Rocket scores higher in terms of SEO
optimization score. As with most of my
comparisons, I would recommend that you
go out and try both of these tools out
for yourselves. When it comes to the
main feature of writing SEO optimized
unique, engaging content, I would say
that Word Rocket does better. Our
content is more unique, especially with
the ability to add your logos in images
or images are just better. And the
overall quality and SEO optimization, as
you saw, is higher when we compare it to
content pen. But I definitely recommend
that you go out, you try it for
yourself, and you be the judge.